l'enterrement du policier tué à lyon
gaston defferre face au malaise de la
police
moscou anniversaire de la révolution
d'octobre l'urss exhibe sa force
militaire
un drame de l'exode des haïtiens refoulé
des états unis rugby un match pour le
plaisir les all blacks sont battus les
barbarians 28 à 18
madame monsieur bonsoir
depuis des mois le malaise couvait entre
la police et son ministre le ministre de
l'intérieur gaston defferre malaise
entretenue chez les policiers par les
nouvelles orientations en matière
d'ordre et de justice engagés par le
gouvernement
entretenue aussi par la recrudescence de
la violence dont souvent les policiers
sont les premiers à faire les frais
aujourd'hui le malaise a éclaté au grand
jour
l'occasion était symbolique et tragique
les obsèques à lyon du brigadier gilbert
a battu mardi dernier par les
cambrioleurs d'une banque
les faits patrick simpson jones les
obsèques du brigadier gilbert se sont
déroulées ce matin en la chapelle de
saint-alban alliant le ministre de
l'intérieur et le ministre de la défense
nationale ainsi que des personnalités de
la police étaient présents à la
cérémonie
le brigadier hubert et un gardien de la
paix avait surpris des malfaiteurs en
flagrant délit dans le quartier des
bretons ces derniers n'avaient pas
hésité à tuer il n'est pas tolérable
non seulement que nous vivions dans un
pareil état d'insécurité mais que ceux
qui sont les gardiens de l'ordre soient
assassinés à l'écart du lieu de
cérémonie plus de 15 cents policiers en
civil et en tenue
formé un cortège qui semble avoir créé
quelques difficultés au moment où les
voitures des 10èmes son côté le ministre
de son côté a ensuite rendu visite aux
gardiens de la paix registar diack qui
avait été grièvement blessé au ventre au
moment du hold up
pendant ce temps le cortège se déplacer
dans la banque où l'agression a vite eu
lieu afin d'y déposer des gerbes
il ya deux hivers à des 46 ans il était
père de deux enfants âgés de 15 et 18
ans le ministre a aussi rappelé les
mesures décidées par le gouvernement
pour renforcer la police
le recrutement de six mille policiers de
plus et l'amélioration de leurs
équipements en dépit de ces mesures est
aussi des gestes que gaston defferre
multiplient depuis quelques temps pour
rassurer les policiers leurs syndicats
ne désarment pas pour l'union des
syndicats catégoriels de la police qui
représentent 30% des policiers en tenue
il s'agit de savoir si les policiers
peuvent compter sur leurs ministres ou
s'ils sont orphelins écoutez son
représentant monsieur al boixe le
ministre de l'intérieur est plus
préoccupé par la politique menée
actuellement par le parti socialiste
et c'est normal c'est un militant
socialiste mais il devrait penser qu'il
est avant tout maintenant la ministre de
l'intérieur de l'état français et qui
lui appartient de se préoccuper de la
sécurité des citoyens et de donner les
moyens à la police d'exercer sa mission
la police a besoin surtout de moyens
moraux se sentir soutenu tant sur le
plan moral que sur le plan matériel et
elle a besoin aussi qu'on prenne en
considération ces problèmes de structure
qui se sont fait jour depuis 1977 où la
police vraiment depuis les décrets
poniatowski a complètement a été
désorganisée et à malaise parmi les
policiers mais ce que vous pensez pas en
même temps
al'inverse qu'il y avait un malaise
aussi dans la population à l'égard de la
police la police française est utilisée
par l'état français et donc par le
gouvernement français elle relève
directement de la politique et qu'elle
était utilisé d'une manière abusive
d'une manière injuste par les
gouvernements précédents c'est le procès
que fait monsieur de faire lui si ça
peut arranger sa politique et qu'il
estime devoir faire le procès des
policiers
soit mais je pense qu'il devrait
davantage s'attaquer à l' institution
archaïque et la police française
plutôt que de s'attaquer aux hommes
est-ce qu'il ne s'agit pas tout le monde
d'une certaine manière d'une réaction de
policiers de droite contre un
gouvernement de gauche absolument pas
vous savez il n'ya pas des policiers de
droite étaient et des policiers de
gauche l'indivision et non il ya des
policiers tout court qui ont le souci
d'exercer leurs missions qui ont un sens
aigu du service public et qui sont là
que pour exécuter les ordres
vous savez on ne demande pas à aucun
policier de prendre quelques initiatives
que ce soit
chaque fait et geste d'un policier est
régi par une circulaire par une auto
service tant qu il appartient à ces
chefs de bien définir ses missions seul
le syndicat cgt police est élevé contre
l'incident de ce matin où il voit à
l'expression de l'hostilité aux
gouvernements de la gauche
un autre syndicat très minoritaire la
fpip a décidé de son côté d'entamer une
procédure judiciaire contre le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est à ce syndicat que
s'en prend gaston defferre
interrogé ce soir à marseille par
corinne pertuis il donne d'abord sa
version des incidents de ce matin
suivi la voiture pilote qui s'est trompé
et nous sommes trouvés à la fin d'un
cortège de deux premiers personnes
j'ai demandé pour ne pas gêner cette
manifestation qui était une
manifestation assez solennel aux jo
faire de faire demi tour
c'est ce que nous avons fait et quand
nous repartions sommes tombés sur un
petit groupe
j'en ai vu personnellement deux ou trois
de personnes dont je ne sais pas si ce
sont des policiers
je ne pense pas que ça puisse être des
syndicalistes qui monte
apostrophé on t'aime peu aimable puisque
je n'ai pas répondu
je n'attache pas grande importance à
cette attitude je tâche d'autant moins
d'importance que j'ai lu les communiqués
qui ont été faits par les grandes
centrales syndicales et qui condamne le
comportement irresponsable
il ne reste pas moins que les syndicats
de police vous reproche d'agir plus un
homme politique
quand chef de la police non c'est un
syndicat d'extrême droite qu'il
représente moins de 1% des voix
quand il ya des élections pour choisir
les responsables des syndicats
il ya 2 ans 0 8% et je vais même vous
faire un aveu être critiquée par un
extrême droite
oui violente est plutôt flatteur pour un
homme comme moi mais d'après vous est-ce
que vous agissez plus un homme politique
quand chef de la police est-ce que c'est
délibéré le pas
et sans distinguer la ou l'autre je suis
homme politique
j'ai de voir des devoirs même en tant
qu'homme politique
j'ai des devoirs en tant que ministre
responsable de la police j'ai donné pour
instruction par exemple à la police de
rechercher les extrémistes ceux qui
commettent tous veulent commettre des
attentats à l'extrême gauche comme à
l'extrême droite et l'extrême droite ne
sont pas satisfaits parce qu'il n'avait
pas l'habitude de cela ces malaises et
la police en fait voulu nier
je nie complètement car le malaise la
police ne peut pas résulter de
déclarations d'hommes qui représente si
peu de choses
alors que les grands syndicats au
contraire que la bord avec moi pour
donner à la police à la fois plus
d'efficacité
une meilleure image un sondage qui
marque un anniversaire celui des six
premiers mois du nouveau septennat 53%
des français estiment les résultats
positifs contre 31% qui pensent le
contraire
c'est ce qui ressort d'un sondage que
publiera demain le journal du dimanche
un autre chiffre intéressant 56 % des
gens interrogés contre 27 % souhaitent
que le régime tente vers la modération
plutôt que la radicalisation
le ministre qui apparaît volontiers
comme le champion de cette ligne modérée
sera lundi soir l'invité de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 il s'agit de jacques delors
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances que vous retrouverez donc lundi
pour affaires vous concernant à
l'assemblée nationale les députés ont
adopté la nuit dernière le budget de
l'agriculture et ce matin celui des ptt
qui est en augmentation de plus de 22%
par rapport à l'an dernier
ce soir les députés examinent le budget
des transports
le secrétaire d'état chargé des
rapatriés raymond courrière a participé
cet après midi à montpellier au congrès
du mouvement du recours
autrement dit le rassemblement et
coordination unitaire des rapatriés et
spoliés d'outre-mer un congrès
intéressant à la lumière des récentes
inquiétudes exprimées par certains
rapatriés
qu'il s'agisse de la commémoration de
nniversaire de la guerre d'algérie où
l'éventuel renvoi des archives en
algérie l'esprit de concertation qui
préside au règlement des premières
mesures prises par le gouvernement est
absolument satisfaisant bien entendu ce
n'est pas terminée il y encore des
problèmes à régler notamment la mystique
et une nouvelle loi d'indemnisation et
l'intégration des français musulmans
dans la communauté nationale
mais je pense que nous sommes
véritablement sur une voie sérieuse et
raisonnable avec le nouveau gouvernement
cette satisfaction est suffisamment
qu'inhabituel chez les adhérents du
recours pour qu'on la souligner ce soir
mais il est vrai qu'au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle ses dirigeants
avaient appelé à voter françois
mitterrand alors ce soir la satisfaction
vient de ce que le secrétaire d'état aux
rapatriés a précisé que le plan global
d'indemnisation annoncé sera discuté
très prochainement au parlement qu'il a
également apaisé les craintes du recours
pour ce qui est du départ de france les
archives concernant l'algérie
moi je considère d'ailleurs comme
beaucoup de rapatriés qu'il s'agit d'une
fausse querelle une querelle politique
destinée à occulter le travail énorme
que nous faisons à l'égard de nos amis
rapatriés qui cherche dans tous les cas
légers les autres que la france n'a
l'intention de brader quoi que ce soit
mais bien entendu toujours de discuter
comme il fallait le faire et qu'on
aurait pu le faire mes prédécesseurs
depuis très longtemps car n'oubliez pas
que ce problème et archives et pendant
depuis 1962 la violence n'a pas de
justification lorsque les conditions du
dialogue existe c'est ainsi que le
secrétaire d'état aux dom-tom
henri emmanuelli condamne les violents
incidents qui viennent de survenir en
nouméa en nouvelle calédonie des
incidents qui confirme l'attention sur
place entre les indépendantistes et les
partisans du maintien de la tutelle
française de nouméa enrichir de fr 3 et
4 ans lorsque ferme la braderie en
plusieurs points de la ville de petit
commente le jeune mélanésiens sortes et
des pierres de leur budget est attaqués
aux vitrines des magasins aux voitures
en stationnement et temps d'allumer
quelques foyers l'ensemble des actions
rapides qui depuis s'est perdue pour
commenter un peu plus loin les postes de
l'ordre réagissent rapidement le sou
durera une
la dizaine de vitrines et agressé
dizaine de magasins une cinquantaine
d'arrestations
quelques blessés légers soir le calme
est revenu sur nouméa you ils sont
désertes des bars concernés
mais la colère il envoie plein sur la
ville transfert fait l'image du jour et
tout en muscles pour marquer le 64e
anniversaire de la révolution d'octobre
le régime soviétique durci le ton et
exhibe sa puissance militaire
dénonciation de l'agressivité accru de
l'impérialisme réaffirmation de la force
soviétique
tels sont les axes en donner à la
cérémonie par le maréchal ustinov le
ministre de la défense jean marc qui
nous au delà de l'univers de rituels des
défilé sur la place rouge on l'attendait
les discours cette année le choix d'une
personnalité militaire était révélateur
et aux côtés d'un président brejnev
apparemment en bonne santé c'est le
maréchal custine of ministre de la
défense d'union soviétique qui a donné
le temps pour dénoncer l' agressivité
accrue des forces de l'impérialisme et
du bloc de l'otan et surtout rappelé que
le rss dispose de forces considérables
l'union soviétique ne permettra pas aux
ennemis de la paix de compromettre la
détente et surtout de rompre l'équilibré
des forces dans le monde
voici quelques-uns des 50000 chars de
l'armée rouge les usa n'en possède que
onze mille pour beaucoup d'experts
militaires occidentaux l'arsenal
atomique de l'urss a rejoint et parfois
dépassé celui des etats unis
pour ce qui concerne missiles
intercontinentaux et ogives nucléaires
par exemple
en raison de l'intervention soviétique
en afghanistan les ambassadeurs de
l'otan avaient boudé le défilé rejoints
cette année par la suède et le danemark
qui n'ont pas vu dans la présence
inopinée d'un sous marin soviétique près
de la base secrète suédoise de
karlskrona la démonstration de la
volonté pacifique évoquée par le
maraîcher destine à l'autre intérêt de
la cérémonie c'était comme à chacune de
ses apparitions publiques
l'occasion d'examiner attentivement
l'état du numéro un soviétique léonid
brejnev
il semble en assez bonne forme il a
gravi d'une seule traite les marches de
la tribune des précautions
exceptionnelles pour ménager sa santé
ont cependant été demandé aux autorités
de bonn où monsieur bré jeunesse doit se
rendre dans quinze jours le gouvernement
allemand a dans l'immédiat
un autre sujet de préoccupation à
francfort depuis cinq jours différents
mouvements écologistes et pacifistes
s'opposent physiquement à
l'agrandissement en plein de forêt de
l'aéroport civil et militaire de
francfort vingt mille manifestants se
sont mises en marche cet après midi pour
tenter de pénétrer sur le chantier après
que les autorités aient repoussé leur
ultimatum
un dispositif policier très important
est en place un conflit dans les sables
ou l'engrenage militaire alimenté par
l'armement soviétiques et américains
risquent à nouveau de faire des ravages
au sahara occidental
le front polisario a décidé de reprendre
sa liberté d'action et donc de ne plus
respecter le plan de paix proposé par
lollia le motif la détermination
évidente des états unis de réarmer le
maroc après la visite sur le terrain
d'une délégation militaire américaine
le ministre de l'information du
polisario l'expliquent à gérard ce bagne
l'introduction de nouvelles armes ne
peuvent en fait que compliquer davantage
la le conflit du sahara occidental et
créer des obstacles dont la solution
pacifique et négocié entre les deux
belligérants maroc et front polisario
oui mais si le maroc introduit des armes
sophistiquées c'est parce que vous même
dit on vous avait introduit ces armes
sophistiquées notamment des femmes si
ces dessins 8 soviétique
au cours de la bataille de galetas
zemmour où vous avez abattu un certain
nombre d'avions marocain tout d'abord
sur cette question nous avons abattu des
avions depuis déjà le début du conflit
la presse internationale témoigne et
ensuite si nous avons ces armes nous
aurons déjà n'ont pas attaqué et
laâyoune au glamour mais ne seront déjà
à rabat donc vous démentez avoir ce type
d'armes nous opposons un démenti
catégorique et nous disons qu'il s'agit
là d'une propagande qui n'est pas
nouvelle du roi du maroc ont voulu
représenter un conflit de décolonisation
comme un conflit entre l'est et l'ouest
pour pouvoir justifier des interventions
étrangères
aux côtés des forces marocaines qui ne
peuvent plus combattre et qui
connaissent l échec total sur le terrain
violents affrontements en iran entre les
forces de l'ordre et les opposants au
régime
il y aurait des dizaines de morts au
nord ouest du pays en azerbaïdjan les
iraniens ont commémoré aujourd'hui en se
flagellant le deuil de l'imam hussein
c'est une fête religieuse essentiel du
calendrier chiite
le rêve américain fait encore des
victimes c'est notre dossier du jour
les etats unis font face depuis les
récents changements de la loi sur
l'immigration un véritable afflux
d'immigrés qui réclament l'asile
politique
jusqu'ici seuls les ressortissants des
pays communistes avaient droit d'office
à l'asile politique
maintenant la provenance importe peu
mais il faut faire la preuve des sévices
dont les candidats à la citoyenneté
américaine serait victime
s'ils rentraient dans leur pays de tous
les immigrés qui affluent depuis
quelques mois ce sont les haïtiens qui
paye le plus cruellement le prix de
leurs espoirs à la française les
américains ont quand même été choqué par
la tragédie qui la semaine dernière a
coûté la vie à 33 migrants clandestins
lorsqu une minuscule parc venus d'haïti
a chaviré à quelques mètres de la côte
une tragédie qui peut changer l'attitude
des américains qui en tout cas a
provoqué une profonde colère dans les
milieux haïtien d'opposition à duvalier
installée aux etats unis avant les
duvalier haïti tpo mais avec les
duvalier en plus la pauvreté on ajoute
la répression politique
la répression systématique pratiquée
palais du valais et l'entourent dans le
mobilier à des pauvres mais c'est pauvre
là ne compte pas se suicider à haute mer
partout en vue de se sauver le président
carter s'est en effet montrée très
libéral en matière d'immigration et au
cours des dernières années plusieurs
milliers d'haïtiens ont pu s'installer
aux etats-unis et si construire une vie
différent travailler une semaine chez
vous
touché une chèque de 233 dollars
ça vaut mieux tuer haïti puisque dans un
mois et y j'ai touché peut-être 50
dollars
peut-être
mais aujourd'hui la réalité est bien
différente
au bout du voyage il y a désormais ce
camp d'internement et la perspective
d'un rapatriement forcé haïti lorsque
les défenseurs des immigrants haïtiens
auront épuisé toutes les subtilités de
procédures de la justice américaine la
tante puis l'expulsion
au terme de mois et de mois de détention
m
mais le coût psychologique et du coup
nous parce que nous ne savons pas ça
maintenant jusque là que nous sommes là
on est là on atteint et vaut mieux que
qu'on vous fera au lieu de vous mais
pour les responsables de l'immigration
il y à la loi en raison de la situation
économique
non seulement aux états unis mais dans
le monde entier les pays sont en train
je crois de revoir leurs lois
d'immigration
est ce que vous devez savoir monsieur
sait qu une loi d'immigration
quel que soit le pays qui la fête est
une loi discriminatoire et de fait le
gouvernement de monsieur reagan a
considérablement durci la politique
d'immigration des états unis parce que
la crise économique a mis beaucoup
d'américains au chômage et que l'arrivée
d'étrangers est de plus en plus mal
supporté par l'opinion publique parce
que les haïtiens sont noirs et que le
sentiment raciste est toujours fort
notamment au sud
parce que le gouvernement de monsieur
duvalier soutenue par l'amérique est
qu'il est dans ces conditions difficile
d'accorder aux haïtiens le statut de
réfugié politique
seul moyen légal de les accepter j'avais
des problèmes avec l'état pour un coût
de l'haïti pour ce que je suis ingénieur
j'avais des problèmes politiques
s'avoue soulagé je suis venu ici avec ma
famille je n'ai vu ni trouver pour moins
par moyens pour vous je vois pas de
l'argent pour aider le parent qui sont
ailleurs
le départ de tr knight et s'attache au
suicide
ouais bon
on voudrait bien tourner mais de toute
façon le tester pour un individu de
faire la preuve qu'il sera soumis à des
persécutions religieuses ou politiques
si jamais il doit retourner dans son
pays
à l'argument des américains libéraux qui
souligne que telle est à l'évidence le
cas des haïtiens et qu'on les traite
plus durement que les réfugiés venus des
pays communistes cuba par exemple les
officiels répondent mais aussi doivent
faire la preuve qu'ils seront soumis à
des persécutions religieuses ou
politiques ne suffit pas d'arriver de
dire que ce sera le cas il faut en faire
la preuve il faut démontrer qu'il en
sera ainsi sort certes le camp n'est pas
un camp de concentration expression
pourtant employé par des journaux
américains
c'est malgré tout une prison même si on
y trouve la télévision et le téléphone
les américains libéraux et les
mouvements noirs n'apprécie guère de
voir qu aux etats unis aujourd'hui des
barbelés sépare des garçons et des
filles de 20 ans
les adversaires de monsieur reagan
s'indigne aussi d'un accord signé entre
le gouvernement américain et haïti qui
permet aux gardes-côtes américains ont
intercepté en pleine mer en mer libre
les bateaux d'haïtiens pour les ramener
de force dans leur pays
la presse américaine est sévère pour
monsieur reagan du sévère à dire vrai
que l'opinion publique
en attendant une hypothétique solution
du problème de haïti cette nuit comme
toutes les nuits des garde-côtes sont
sortis en patrouille à la recherche de
rescapés d'un illusoire voyage vers
l'espoir si les haïtiens sont refoulés
les immigrés cubains eux continuent
d'être accueilli le régime cubain
s'attend d'ailleurs au pire de la part
de l'administration reagan selon le
ministre cubain de la culture dans une
interview au journal le monde c'est sans
grand enthousiasme que les belges vont
voter demain pour la deuxième fois en
moins de trois ans ils doivent élire
députés et sénateurs pour définir une
nouvelle carte politique qui permettent
la constitution d'un gouvernement après
la démission en septembre dernier du
gouvernement et skins pour la première
fois l'âge du vote qui est obligatoire a
été abaissé à 18 ans si la campagne
électorale a été morne
l'enjeu des élections est crucial et
leur issue incertaine
devant la complexité des problèmes
économiques et linguistique qui accable
la belgique
un fait divers dramatique qui a eu lieu
hier soir et qui devrait faire réfléchir
beaucoup de parents à épinay-sur-seine
deux enfants de 12 et 9 ans ont été
abattus par jeu d'un coup de fusil de
chasse par un enfant de neuf ans et demi
il joué à se faire peur en un an en
france près d'une dizaine d'enfants sont
morts dans les mêmes circonstances
absurde alors surtout surtout si vous
détenez des armes à feu boucler
l'histoire du jour est une belle
histoire sportive car c'est vraiment
pour le plaisir qu'on a joué au rugby
cette après midi à bayonne les
barbarians français affrontaient les
redoutables néo zélandais les all-blacks
ils se sont fait battre 28 à 18
un résultat que les néo-zélandais ont
pris eux ou sérieux avant le match de
samedi prochain daniel kazan
les variantes sont un club privé où l'on
entre sur invitation pour un quart par
pigeon qui arrivent huit même barbare y
en ait grand absent de cette rencontre
explique qu'il faut remplir trois
conditions aimer le rugby et mais
l'offensive être aussi fair play sur le
terrain que dans la vie sur le terrain
les barbarians se distinguent par leur
numéro mais aussi par leur show sec
chacun d'eux porte les chaussettes de
son club d'origine avec les barbarians
une chose est sûre on a droit au rugby
ouvert confie d'attac classique un jeu
plein de panache qui fait se dresser un
stade entier comme un seul homme cette
volonté d'attaquer à outrance de faire
voler le ballon de main en main n'est
pas toujours couronnée de succès mais
qu'importe pour les barbarians
l'essentiel c'est de s'amuser gagner est
une préoccupation secondaire
les all blacks étaient venus à bayonne
dans un tout autre état d'esprit battu
mercredi à grenoble par une sélection
française il avait à coeur de venger cet
affront et de préparer du même coup le
test match de samedi prochain à toulouse
voilà pourquoi jouant avec plus de
rigueur ils ont profité à la 12e minute
de leur première action offensive pour
marquer un essai par leur centre shaun
un essai digne des meilleurs joueurs du
monde que sont ces néo zélandais
les efforts des barbarians salle est
enfin aboutir peu avant la mi-temps
après ce regroupement
martinez donne à viviès passe sautée de
viviès pour merlos vers l'os qui se
profile comme une anguille dans la
défense des néo-zélandais un essai qui
rend encore plus amère les citrons de la
mi temps en seconde mi-temps les all
blacks menaient 12 à 6 parviendront à
leurs fins grâce à trois essais de
pénalité et un drop
ils battront les barbarians 28 à 18 mai
pour randy levine l'arrière écossais
invitait des barbarians et auteur de 14
points
qu'importe le score pourvu qu'on ait
l'ivresse d'un bel après midi de rugby
le deuxième lancement de la navette
spatiale américaine columbia aura lieu
jeudi prochain à 13h30 heure française
les deux filtres les deux générateurs
qui avait été à l'origine du report du
lancement mercredi dernier ont été
nettoyés une image surprenante l'image
d'un geyser qui a fait irruption en
france ça nectaire une colonne d'eau
chaude à 55° jaillit toutes les 8
minutes
la semaine prochaine on ne le verra plus
on va essayer de le domestiquer avec une
pompe pour ranimer l'établissement
thermal qui est tout proche
maintenant quel temps pour demain
laurent broomhead pas de geysers d'eau
chaude servie de dire que sur le front
de la météo c'est un petit peu le statu
quo vous savez quand un anticyclone
s'installe sur le pays faut-il l'oeil il
bouge plus alors on est protégé malgré
tout aujourd'hui il ya eu des des
paquets de nuages sont arrivés sont
nord-est du pays un air un peu plus
humide mais ils sont en train de se
désagréger si bien que sur la carte de
demain millions des coûts surtout du
soleil aura encore des nuages sur le
nord du massif montagneux de l'est du
pays
vous voyez de la brume tenace dans le
sud-ouest et les brouillards givrants
dans le sandre le nord-est et dans le
nord il faut dire que s'il ya du soleil
l'après-midi en revanche le matin il
fera froid et même de plus en plus froid
puisque sur notre liste de température
on pourrait remplacer les 0° d'hier par
des - de oud et -3° pense qu'on va voir
ses températures qui s'échelonnent donc
de zéro à -2 dans le centre et dans le
nord jusqu'à tumen 5 degrés dans l'ouest
et 7 degrés dans le sud est le matin
l'après-midi comme aujourd'hui de 9 à 15
degrés en général enfin il y à l'agenda
pour terminer si vous voulez tout savoir
christine je vous dirais que l'inde y
est bien des nuages est donc un temps
plus doux reviendront sur le nord ouest
du pays merci pour votre prochain
journal à 23h30 avec jacques merlino
demain antennes de midi bernard langlois
a la chance de recevoir jean marais
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal je vous
en rappelle les titres le ministre de
l'intérieur gaston defferre confronté au
malaise des policiers lors de
l'enterrement de l'un d'entre eux a
battu à lyon à moscou démonstration de
force militaire à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire de la révolution
d'octobre
en rugby les bars variance battue par
les all blacks ça bayonne bonne soirée
sur antenne 2 je vous retrouve demain à
20 heures